this is the extent of what nearly became
the UK's largest ever wildfire
this is the Scottish Highlands near
kanek and five days after it started the
fire is still burning it's devastating
for the area's Wildlife there are a
whole range of uh
and Argent and Sable moths which are all
very much housed within this habitat
this time of year they're breeding and
reproducing so sadly these these these
creatures and animals don't move fast
enough to outrun or outfly fire
extinguishing a fire of this size needs
big resources at its height nine fire
trucks were mobilized a helicopter water
bombed the area
fires like this can be the result of a
buildup of dead grass and Heather left
over from last year they dry quickly as
temperatures rise what was unusual was
the behavior of the fire at this
incident you can see from the footage on
the ground that there was a very strong
smoke plume uh the color of the smoke
all indicative of very extreme fire
behavior and by that I mean large flames
and a fast-moving fire front and that is
something that we'd expect to see in
Mediterranean fuels in the summer in
Canada members of the public are being
urged to be careful close windows and
doors don't walk dogs where helicopters
are at work the fire service Ash does
For assistance with helicopters so we
brought in a helicopter on Monday uh
second helicopter on Tuesday and both
helicopters have been in action ever
since in terms of water bombing
um the fire locations
a wildfire warning in place across East
Central and Southern Scotland has been
extended until Monday
Sadia Chowdhury Sky News